الى شبكه مراسلين في اوكرانيا من ميكولايز
تامر الصمادي ومن دونيسك سلام خضر تامر مع
استمرار القصف على ميكو لايف ما الذي
يتكشف
[موسيقى]
نعم جلال بالفعل القصف الروسي وفقا للقوات
الاوكرانيه يتواصل على ميكولايب وعديد
المقاطعات الجنوبيه الحديث عن خيرسون
المجاوره بالاضافه ايضا
المجاوره وزباروجيا وادين برو وعديد
المناطق الجنوبيه جبهات القتال الجنوبيه
كان لافتا حديثا سلاح الجو الاوكراني خلال
الساعه الاخيره بان المقاطعات الجنوبيه
تتعرض
للاستهداف من قبل المسيرات الايرانيه
الصنع التي تستخدمها القوات الروسيه كما
قال وتحدث عن اسقاط 10 طائرات من دون طيار
من اصل 15 استهدفت ميكو لايف تحديدا
وخيرسون
وتقول السلطات الاوكرانيه بان القصف يتكثف
على محطات المياه في اشتوكه بالاضافه الى
المناطق الساحليه هذا القصف كما تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه جلال ادى الى انقطاع
المياه بشكل كامل عن المقاطعه التي نتواجد
فيها منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى بالاضافه
الى التيار الكهربائي الحديث عن انقطاع
شبه تام في اودسلي الكهرباء والمياه ايضا
والحال ليس احسن في خيرسون حيث تنقطع
المياه
والشبكه الكهرباء بشكل متواصل منذ ايام
طويله منذ انسحاب القوات الروسيه الى
الطرف الاخر من نهر دنيبر تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه ايضا تحديدا قياده عمليات
الجنوب ان هناك مواجهات مستحيه مستعره على
طول خطوط الجبهه بين ميكولايبسو تحديدا في
بعض المناطق الساحليه في خير سون قالت
السلطات العسكريه هناك الاوكرانيه بان
المدينه تعرضت لاكثر من 70 هجوما خلال
ساعات الفجر الاولى وحتى هذه الساعه تقول
بان القصف يتكتف على المدينه وعديد الكره
الواقعه على خطا التماس التي افرغت بشكل
كبير من قبل من السكان ايضا هنالك مواجهات
مستعره ك يقول السلطات عنوانها المدفعيه
ونحن رصدنا هذه الاشتباكات يوم امس لا
تكاد تمر خمس دقائق 10 دقائق الا ويتجدد
القصف المدفعي المتبادل بين الطرفين على
طول الضفتين نهر دنيبر تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه ايضا بانها رصدت خلال الساعات
الماضيه يعني محاوله لمزيد بناء من
التحصينات من قبل القوات الروسيه
المتواجده على الطرف الاخر من انها الضفه
الشرقيه وتقول ايضا بانه لم يعد بمقدورها
نقل السكان العالقين في المناطق الشرقيه
مناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه في
خيرسون الى الطرف الاخر الذي تسيطر عليه
القوات الاوكرانيه نهايه تحدثات خلال
الساعات الاخيره ايضا عن مقتل امراه مسنه
كانت تحاول ان تقطع انهار النهر من الجهه
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه باتجاه
الضفه الاخرى لكن ذلك او الرصاص القوات
الروسيه كما قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه لم
يسعفها نعم السلام
همم الضباب خلفك يحجب صوره الدمار ولكن
هناك معلومات من السلطات المواليه لروسيا
حول ما اسفر عنه القصف الاوكرانيه المستمر
منذ امس الجمعه ولكن نريد ان نعرف تفاصيل
اكثر معك من الصوره خلفك وايضا من
التفاصيل الوارده حتى الان
[موسيقى]
مياده نبدا من حيث انتهيتي هذا الضباب
الذي ترونه خلفي لم يحجب الرؤيه لكنه لم
يوقف القصف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه بينما نحن
نتحدث اليكم نسمع بوضوح ضربات صادره من
المواقع الروسيه ضربات مدفعيه تتجه على ما
يبدو الى المواقع الاوكرانيه الاقرب الى
مدينه
حده القتال عند المناطق القريبه من دونيت
لا تزالوا مشتعله منذ اكثر من ثمانيه ايام
يترافق ذلك مع تكرار الاستهدافات
الاوكرانيه لوسط مدينه دنيتك والمناطق
المحيطه بها ليله امس استهدفت مناطق وسط
المدينه بقصف صاروخيه اوكراني بقيت
النيران تشتعل باكثر من مكان في احد
المنازل واحد الابنيه السكنيه اضافه الى
سوق السهدفه للمره الثانيه على الاقل في
غضون ايام حتى الان تقول السلطات ان عدد
القتلى توقف عند قتيل واحد نتيجه قصف ليله
امس وثلاثه جارحه اصيب ايضا في قصف ليله
امس احدى انابيب الغاز التي تغذي مدينه
دمياط بغاز التدفئه وبهذا تكون مناطق
واسعه من العاصمه او ما تسمى عاصمه
الانفصاليين مدينه دنيتك قد خرجت عن العمل
احدى محطات الطاقه الكهربائيه الرئيسيه
واحدى محطات التزوج بالمياه اضافه الى خط
انابيب غاز هناك اربعه احياء على الاقل
مساحه لا تقل عن 120 كيلو متر مربع باتت
دون تدفئه دون مياه ودون كهرباء نشير
اخيرا الى مساله الى ان السلطات المحليه
تكرر تحذيراتها للسكان انه عند سماع القصف
الاوكراني يجب التوجه الى المنازل وايضا
تدعو جميع السكان نتيجه استهداف الاحياء
السكنيه بالتحديد مياده الى ابقاء مداخل
المنازل المفتوحه عندما يبدا القصف
الاوكراني عاده او انت وجد بعض المشاه في
شوارع المدينه قد يضطرون للهروب تقول
السلطات ان ابقاء ابواب المنازل مفتوحه قد
تساهم بانقاذ حياه السكان مياده من دنيا
السلام خضر ومن ميكو لايف تامر صمادي شكرا
جزيلا لكم